Hey, Dad.
I have a really
exciting idea, okay?
You seem pretty
lonely in here,
and something pretty
exciting is going on
just across the road
over there.
Uh...
Dad, don't you want
to lead a five-star life?
Yeah, um...I am worried.
You know, worried
is not the right word.
I'm wondering...
slash worried
that this might turn out
like the model-airplane
club sophomore year.
This isn't gonna be
anything like that, Dad.
For one thing, my followers
love me out there.
(Forrest voice-over)
It was a low blow for my father
to bring up
my disastrous leadership
of Model Airplane Club.
Now I was determined
to prove to him
that I could lead a cult
as well as anyone.
I began following the wisdom
of cult leaders
who had succeeded before me.
First, I granted myself
the extraordinary power
of absolving the sins
of my followers.
Who else has a burden
to unleash?
I stole money from
the pension fund at work.
The stars absolve you!
(all)
One, two, three, four, five!
I cheated on my husband
with a total stranger.
The stars definitely
absolve you.
(all)
One, two, three, four, five!
I hit a homeless man
with my car,
and I just kept driving.
- Seriously?
- Yeah, I did.
The stars absolve you!
(all)
One, two, three, four, five!
My children,
I have taken your sins
and transgressions
and crimes,
and I have banished
them into the deep,
dark void of space.
- We are free!
- [cheers and applause]
(Forrest voice-over)
Then, to keep everyone focused
on me and being more like me,
I instituted a new uniform.
- Here.
- We have a new uniform!
(Forrest voice-over)
And a reward system.
As you earn each level,
you will get a new piece
of clothing.
The first level
of achievement is shirts.
Th second level is pants.
Let's hope you get
to that one soon.
The third level is jacket.
The fourth level is tie.
And level five--the glasses
of enhanced sight.
(Forrest voice-over)
And it was all working
beautifully.
(Forrest)
Congratulations.
You've attained Shirt Level.
(Forrest voice-over)
Two months into our time
together,
the members
of my rapidly growing family
were beginning
to treat me like a messiah.
[applause]
And I liked being a messiah.
Cosmic Father, this is all
I have in the world,
made out to you
in a cashier's check.
- Congratulations.
- Yes, indeed.
Cosmic Father,
it's my father's old watch.
You're my father now.
- One, two three--
(all) Four, five.
Rachel?
You haven't surrendered
your assets to the movement yet.
I just don't think I can,
Cosmic Father.
Well, I would hate
for anyone to find out
about the man that you
hit with your car.
A cashier's check
will be just fine.
(all)
One, two, three, four, five.